[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake and
super excited to be talking about
normalizing cannabis we have an awesome
guest for doing so
Jim MacAlpine hey how you doing thanks
for coming out of the show Matt thanks
for having me really appreciate him
really excited I'm so happy that you've
founded and been running new West Summit
which is how I met you I'm seeing for
you the last two years yeah we did
partnership interviews this last year
those were super fun with all of them
are out now which is great they're all
they're all in the channel guys go check
them out great people Steve DeAngelo and
just watching mine yeah granddaddy Mike
so many cool people in that mix in new s
summit the world's leading cannabis tech
conference been doing that for years
founded that founded for 20 games and
for 20 games has just been again
normalizing cannabis like really
athletes that are going out running 4.2
4.20 miles yeah yep it's actually a 5k
is 3 miles 3.1 miles actually so we call
it it not just to be kitschy but we're
going the extra mile for cannabis so we
run one more mile than those 5k people
just to say what and so many other
important that you care so much about
this for the sake of people that are
addicted to opiates people that are just
distinct Mathai zhing it for like kin of
dads and kin of athletes like there's so
many things that you do is speaking as
well and so this is this is great I'm
really looking forward to talking about
all of this thank you my friend like I
said before we went on camera I feel
like we're very very lucky to be alive
and experience and actualize this I mean
with we were 10 years before or 10 years
after this is a very very important time
in history and we're the ones who are
getting to make that history so I feel
blessed and when we were talking in
Grand a Mike and Steve Angello I mean
these guys were teaching us about the
50-year history leading up to this point
and it was blood sweat tears it's a big
deal getting to this point I like to
make sure I always pay respect to those
guys I've been in the industry for five
years I've been more or less a consumer
since I've been I won't quote the age
but so I really like to pay respect to
guys like Steve and Mike and funny story
like when I started the 420 games I
didn't know who Steve D'Angelo was or
even Harborside because I hadn't really
been in the industry were in the Hat
we'll shoot two days into it I get an
email from this guy and I look his name
and it's name is Steve do you know and I
googled him and I was like oh my god
this is this is a real dude and I went
and met Steve and he was from literally
day one Steve's one of the people I need
to thank cuz he supported me like right
from the get-go and been a mentor more
or less yeah yeah and so I mean for 20
games is nuts
like five cities a year okay yeah before
we get there let's talk about you so
born Stockton then Atherton's have been
around the bay whole life yep and then
like how did you venture into cannabis
well make it a short story but my past
career was in the ski and snowboard
industry and we had a pretty severe
four-year drought where the lack of snow
meant lack of revenue and it really
really hurt me and my company
financially so making it very short I
had one day said to my wife I don't
think my company's gonna be around much
longer I'm gonna drive up to Tahoe to
our cabin I'm gonna bring a bag of weed
and I'm gonna smoke this until I figure
out what my next job is and when I sat
down before I even packed my bowl vais
came on and it was a special called the
Green Rush and it like just slapped me
across the face and I sat up all night
right in the business plan for the 4/20
games that night and smoking with snow
for years of snow way it just didn't
snow I mean there was a drought you know
the huge California drought I mean it
was beyond the ski industry it hurt
everything in California and
probably partially why these fires have
happened and yeah those four years were
incredibly hard for the entire
California agriculture and tourism you
know industry but the ski industry when
it doesn't snow you know mother nature
dictates your your fortune or lack of
and it was a bad few years damn and so
um snow bomb was doing online lift
tickets
yeah like kind of like the Fandango of
skiing you know you could buy your
tickets online they were they were
cheaper as well and just bring with the
bar code to the resort so yeah it was
fun while it lasted but I actually say
that the one good thing that came out of
the drought is it forced me to jump into
this because I love what I'm doing now
more than anything I've ever done yeah
that's such a good thing to hear when
somebody is speaking with that much
confidence and love for what they do I
love that well that's the type of energy
that I want every human to feel on the
planet like I wake up every day and I
love what I do like that's the best ok
so you wrote that business plan for for
20 games and then you you know got hit
up hi Steve DeAngelo in the first couple
of Todd days that you were working yeah
I put a posted online or something and
he saw it in him
you know contacted me right away and the
first the first like City where you did
this was San Francisco Golden Gate Park
yep okay cool and we have a we have that
we have the graphic is that from the
first year I think the video we have is
from 2017 for 20 games so a couple years
ago okay so were three years ago
actually three years ago nowadays and
then and then that's right in in Golden
Gate Park who over by calc Adam of
Sciences it's the bandshell area right
there yeah yep and so now like okay so
walk us through like what is you know
there's so much in the normalization of
cannabis by doing something like 420
games but what was the big like aha for
you for getting that rolling well I mean
ultimately I am someone up until I did
this for me it was it was a coming out
of the closet if you will because I've
been an executive and an entrepreneur
that sits with other executives and has
to go to meetings and you know the
Christmas party it's fine for everyone
to get blacked out but if you lit a
joint you'd be a pariah you know so
I felt like I'd had to live in the
closet my whole life I was a starting
forward in my soccer team starting
pitcher I'm I was a good athlete I
wasn't a pro athlete but I was pretty
good and I always smoked weed before I
played because it helped me make get my
mind right you know and so for me it was
like a true passion in my art that a
life that I lived and it just it was an
opportunity for me to kind of be I
always think of Spartacus you know I
stepped out first but then someone sees
me step out and so now it's become a
social movement to be honest with you I
can it was so interesting to the media
when I first did this because no one had
heard of this before but now it's like
there's literally a social movement of
thousands and thousands of people that
define themselves as kin athletes you
know and they're proud of it so I think
it's an amazing thing to see where we've
counted thousands of people are
identifying as kin of athletes now it
wasn't Phelps was one of the first big
ones right yeah well I mean I use
Michael Phelps the new Saint bolt as one
of my examples so the fastest man in
history and water and the fastest man in
history and land are both known cannabis
users you know that makes a pretty large
statement boom yeah and this is
interesting so I think if you look back
in history the one group of people that
was culturally on some level allowed to
use cannabis where the artists and the
musicians because of it their
creativeness and there's something
called flow state I don't know if you
know what that is but athletes go into
flow state when you're a top level
athlete you don't think you do and so I
see I think there's a very much a
synergy or an analogy there between like
they're they're the same thing these
artists these athletes they're using it
as a gateway to flow State and so it's
not a gateway to higher drop worse drugs
it's a really is something that helps
you get your mind in a place of extreme
focus yes yes so there's all these
different uses for the different
cannabinoids and the different dosages
the the different methods of intake
ingestion or inhalation or topicals yeah
so many yeah methods now because they're
all that usually they can all kind of
get you to different places some for
this creative actualization some for
like really hyper like focus flow some
from complete
medicinal yeah yeah you don't have to
use it to get high you can use CBD for
your pain and not use the the
psychoactive component of the plant and
I'm a proponent of edibles because on
the athlete side you know the less smoke
you take into your lungs the better and
personally I like the high of an edible
that lasts longer and a little more
heavy hitting so you know multifaceted
reasons for using the edibles so now so
I mean this is you what so they do the
4.2 mile run mm-hmm and then we do yoga
before so we start off with yoga as a
warm-up we do the 4.20 mile run we
usually do a second yoga session and
then you know in LA this is the LA for
20 games at the Santa Monica Pier here
we also this year had a three-on-three
basketball tournament led by NBA
professional al harrington we had an arm
wrestling contest led by Frank Shamrock
and bas Rutten who are two heavyweight
UFC champions we had a skateboard
contest at the legendary Venice skate
bowl led by Bucky lassic who is a very
very big name yeah and we had Jiu Jitsu
I mean so it's not just running so Rogan
would love to get behind a Joe if I can
get to you Joe come on man I've been
trying so let's get you out for the four
20-game shows a big role model for us I
love Jimmy J I mean I watch his podcast
the guys let's get him on for 20 games
so scared let's feel let's ask him again
I'll keep knocking - let's keep let's
knock let's knock yeah think that's it
yeah you've had a major mention in
different sports like that's huge it's a
lot of different sports yeah well if you
think of it - like my background is not
necessarily team sports I played in high
school but I I went into being a skier
and a snowboarder and a surfer and so
action sports are very different than
team sports then that's why I wanted to
bring this whole side of like the X
Games world into it as well so we've got
both these NFL and NBA guys but then
we've got Shaun White and all that kind
of world as well and they're both just
as talented and amazing of athletes and
then you have people playing a game of
chess yes I always appreciated playing a
little chess after some cannabis there's
like everything from the crave the crazy
skateboarders and
and BMXers and stuffed jiu-jitsu and
they're doing a tag they're doing like
moving around the camp yeah we had kind
of like CrossFit II competitions where
you carry big things and do you like
beats of strength if you will yeah and
honestly one other thing that there's a
lot of top-level high like one of our
runners is a one of the top three ultra
marathoners in the world but this is not
built just for extreme and professional
athletes like after they run there's
probably more people that actually
either jog or walk the course and I want
to inspire people to get off the couch
and it's right you don't have to go run
like if you walk 4.20 miles you get to
burn the same amount of calories you
know so it's just about movie not being
at the fit you know first to the finish
line yeah yeah that that's a really
important part of this message getting
the actual movement out there also you
know setting a goal for yourself and
going in and making a statement like in
order to actually do what you you know
some people are challenged with you know
with weight and whatnot and you know
that message that you just said they're
so powerful to get people moving note so
that says crazy now because it's been
five years and about five per year so
it's like 25 different events Portland
Seattle Denver LA SF San Diego
Pittsburgh Boulder as well yeah that's
big that's huge and that so civilized
ended up yeah I'm honored to have a
company like civilized dot life acquire
us yes I've always admired the the
quality of media that they put out and
it was a natural partnership because
what they do through media and film is
what I do through athletics and we're
not we're normalizing cannabis and we're
putting a new face on it and so it was a
very I call it a Reese's Peanut Butter
partnership because the chocolate and
the peanut butter come together and it's
even better you know we were collabs
like that and you can call it after like
you know Reese's or peanut butter jelly
you know there's really good ones have
an egg yeah yeah yeah that this one's a
really good one because civilized is the
kind of like D like you said the perfect
partner they're really doing the
normalization of cannabis they're gonna
take us international too because
they're actually based in Canada as well
as Los Angeles so we'll have a Toronto
422 the second coming here which will
take us to the international status yeah
that's exciting
okay so now okay so that's for 20 games
for 20 games is you know doing it's in
normalizing cannabis but then there's
this you know civilize is doing their
big sort of Congress on on the future of
cannabis across the world but new West
Summit does its own you know Congress of
tech and business folks in the industry
and so now that that's been rolling
you've seen quite a bit of you know how
many deals are probably done at you know
New West summit every single year like a
lot yeah it's really fun honestly like
in four years to watch the radical
professionalization and just how
everything has changed from not too long
ago it's really really cool to see you
know and we've we've got a little bit of
time still before the the big you know
huge dollars come in and it's gonna be a
different landscape so right now I don't
want to call it a land grab but I think
people need to be very cognizant of what
they're building how they build it
because it's not gonna be you know
around where all US little guys can be
doing what we're doing for forever so
it's about positioning right now yeah
it's totally about positioning and you
know Gary Vee Gary Vaynerchuk was just
out in LA doing Yammer on you got a
thought yeah actually I'm frightened
with this talk so yeah it's scary
cuz the war on drugs we were talking
about it earlier they killed people and
now with decriminalization and industry
and money to be made it's always you
know money is the root of all evil well
not necessarily but yeah we're
free-spirited talking like this they'll
kill us he shut your mouth there don't
stomp smart with this talk yeah
positioning you know that strategic
terms you know strategy if I disappear
won't you guys but you know let's pick
you back on that thought a little bit
more so you know you're talking about
the last couple of years have been
you've seen people actually start
positioning and taking footing and
building up their brands and and that's
really cool to see that happening and
then you also kind of see this interest
coming in from the big dogs so four
billion dollars was invested by
Constellation Brands which they owned a
lot of wine er wine brands and other
alcohol brands so for with a B that's I
like to call that four thousand million
dollars that was put into a company
called canopy growth in Canada and
they're actually the parent the the lead
investor and civilized that that it
acquired my event so yeah I mean that's
that's not playing around money and
those that's a big big alcohol company
and many others are circling around
right now too
so during this time what I love for the
most part is your heart matters still in
this industry people don't want to work
with the wrong people I'll use a great
example there's a guy named Dan
Bilzerian he's a big Instagram star you
know it's got a big beer duties muscley
and he basically objectifies women and
has girls in bikinis and you know he
doesn't put the face on being feminine
the way I'd like to see it done and no
one will work with the guy I mean
everyone I know and I've seen he's
launched his own cannabis brand yeah you
know basically everyone's like [ __ ] you
dan Bilzerian I don't want to work with
you you're an [ __ ] and that's get a
picture of them no can we do that isn't
daxing the big thing aren't we can't we
do that we sure although he is I don't
replug you know
I'm just saying you know this guy I
never heard about him and I and I share
your opinion about you know I'm anti
objectifying of women I'm doing the best
I can I'm seeing your man here so I grew
up with that it was normal for me in one
way or another you know so I'm trying to
you know gain that respect and and who
else this guy's name again I'll go find
him and I'll get the damn thing here
we'll well you know we'll we'll
Wiltshire well we'll show this is what
you don't want to be when you're
marketing your products and they
cannabis or oh this is this is this is
his he's a poker guy he made his made
his moolah doing poker and so anyway so
he has a cannabis brand and so there's a
heart there's a whole aspect of heart to
this which is if you if you if you keep
around a strong genuine intention of
wanting to you know like it was at the
end of there's at the end of I think the
show with granddaddy Mike that we did
when he said that your year you're
either what did he say
you're either in it for the money or
you're not is what he said and I think
what it's pretty sure that's what it was
like but anyway the point is is that you
know you're either trying to come in
here for the the land rush the gold rush
the cannon rush etc or you're coming in
here to try and yeah there's something I
don't want to pick on your granddaddy
Mike but I will kind of give a different
perspective because I and and many
others like Steve and Mike all those
guys myself included I think you like
the plant means something to us the
plant courses through my veins like I am
I am cannabis and I love cannabis and I
always have and that's like it's a
passion to me and you can feel it and
its exude it in my work and what I do
but there is something in America and I
want I want I would like to make a lot
of money doing this as well and there's
nothing wrong with that and I think
there's a philosophy out there pretty
prevalent that you can't make money
while doing good you know and I think
the exact opposite should be if you're
able to do both it's going to bring more
good to this world so to stigmatize
people that are going to make
just because they're making money while
doing good it's it's basically saying
you know killing the the desire to do
that so I think there's a real paradigm
shift that needs to house is so
interesting that we've started exploring
the nuance of that statement because
there's the there's the hyper I'm in it
for just the money
and there's the hyper I'm in it for none
of the money and then there's this inch
very interesting nuance middle which is
I'm in it to make the world better and
make money and then don't and then make
the money so that I can keep making the
world better and keep doing things like
good with the money we make and have a
you know good ethics and morals around
it so that's the one thing in this
industry I guess that I started saying
is that I think we all are looking to
make sure that we keep the good guys
aboveboard and the the bad guys get
weeded out pretty quickly pun intended
bad guys get weeded out as a good one so
um let's talk about the you know let's
talk about the brand so yeah you got can
athlete you got can of dads you got
what's what are the caramels under again
so these caramels here I've got two
edible lines and this first one is
called choose love they're really
amazing a line of different types of
caramels these are a vegan coconut
caramel and I partnered with a friend of
mine this is the product that I was
buying and I liked and I was like I'm
gonna go find the guy that makes this
because I want to work with him and he
was a really cool guy and we partnered
brought his brand under our brand to
Canada a fleet and now it's a the two
edible lines that were selling and
manufacturing and they're good I'm gonna
eat one right now yeah and I'm too and
Ron already added it did choose choose
love yeah vegan coconut caramel 5
milligram CBD 5 milligram TC and this is
so interestingly enough the 5 milligram
ores are they're like really good for a
micro dose of cannabis you know these
really don't get you too
you're not gonna be like sitting in the
corner in that bad place where you've
overdosed on inedible at five milligrams
that's for sure
I actually honestly tell most people two
point five milligrams if you're just
starting is probably a better place than
yard just really avoid having any form
of too much psycho activity I just ate
half and it's it's really good
thank you it's really good it yeah it
did yeah it doesn't taste it tastes like
a caramel yeah no it's really well made
that's why I was drawn to it because
like I it's kind of dangerous because
they taste so good you're like one more
and you don't wait how long do you gotta
wait like 30 40 minutes before yeah I
would say like with a true edible
product like when you're eating it it's
it's closer to 45 minutes to an hour ish
yeah yeah and then with our spray this
is this is called cannon athlete it's up
I like to use the word activate
activated instead of getting high so
this is called our activation spray
that's made for focus its micro dose at
1 milligram of THC in 1 milligram of CBD
so it's 5 times more of a micro dose
than the caramel we were just talking
about so it's built like literally like
you will not get high if you squirt this
once in your mouth and you can really
calculate how much you want to use and
get yourself where you want to be mm-hmm
very specifically yeah yeah are you guys
the first ones they're making up I
haven't seen a mouth spray yet or you
know what through the mouth there's one
or two others out there but this one
which is an MC tea coconut oil is very
formulated swiss specificity to athletes
I don't think there's really anything
else out there like that there's another
kind of breath spray spray out there but
it's kind of for a different purpose
again this is big for athletes cuz they
can just go you know pop out and done
and you're you know right back in and
it's not harmful for their lungs yeah
and this is technically what they call
on some levels tincture or somewhat like
a tincture because you can spray this
right under your tongue and it'll go
into your bloodstream quicker so as
opposed to that you'll probably feel
this within call it 30 minutes
is an hour so that the activation into
your bloodstream goes quicker when
you're spraying it sub it's called
sublingually sublingual yeah nice so
that's what I'm gonna see I've learned
something new yeah it's sublingual
interesting so yeah and you have
different pathologies you have different
you're secure so here's a one milligram
spray this is a 10 milligram spray
yes that's yeah that's a big jump so
it's an order of magnitude that smite
reserved on the market that's for daddy
I have a high tolerance yeah yeah cuz
you can pop a couple
yes phrases that this one in your you
know I'm gonna do I'm gonna do spray the
one yeah this is unflavored MCT oil
correct yeah yeah and MCT oils like big
for all the people that care about their
health nowadays yeah bulletproof coffee
in less stuff so yeah okay let's do this
so this one's unflavored but this one's
peppermint flavor yeah these are these
are sample models so we just had a
different you know a few different lines
to to try I like the peppermint because
it's got that little burn to it and it
feels more mediciney when you do it yeah
yeah discreet and easy so that's a brand
new one so you had a little air in the
tube there boom nice so this is awesome
now is can they can people go on
actually we have we have we have a we
have it up right here so on cannon a
fleet get canít get can at athlete calm
and links in the bio to we have the
webpage up here now can they place an
order online no well technically like
you know through other services you can
get online orders or order delivery but
since we're actually the manufacturer
we're not technically able to sell it to
the general public it has to go through
the retail channels so we produce it in
Oakland and then we were actually just
coming to market and so we're not
actually in dispensaries yet but it's in
the in the final stages of being this
tributed in mostly in northern
california and then we're gonna be
focusing on Southern California but the
markets are so different that we're
really just distributed in Northern
California no no no Jim is the case that
you can't distribute through the
internet yet is that like you can't do
direct a consumer of via well you can if
you are a if you have a retail license
so it's a very very interesting
regulatory market with cannabis and when
I say interesting I mean [ __ ] up yes
so the laws change all the time and
we've been very much over regulated with
any new thing like this you have to
expect that regulations are gonna be at
the highest level and then slowly come
down but yeah it's it's a bit of a [ __ ]
show and there's a lot of people
including myself that are still
struggling to figure out how to be
compliant which is a very important
piece of the puzzle so yeah we've got
another year or two as as a producer of
cannabis products it's very confusing
and it's not easy to work with the state
of California right now so we're moving
in the right direction but very slowly
and very painfully to be honest and what
are those obstacles and when we're
dealing with the state and this whole
process well so there's something called
the Bureau of cannabis control and
there's a lady named Laurie Ajax that
runs that and I don't I'm not pointing a
finger or faulting her in any way shape
or form it's it's much bigger than any
one person but there are so many
different rules and and many of them
just don't make sense and so what
they've done and this makes sense to me
they it's like alcohol you know you if
you make beer or you make spirits you
don't sell that direct you have to find
a distributor to sell that so just like
in alcohol if you produce cannabis you
have to find a distributor and have a
distributor distribute for you or you
can get your own distribution license
and become what's called
vertically-integrated
which would mean you know you produce
your own flour and you turn it into
product and then you distribute it and
if you're fully vertically integrated
you would also own a dispensary so from
flower to shelf you own the whole
process which is the smartest way to do
it I'm unfortunately not at that stage
and I'm just
- producer mm-hmm now now you bring up
California Bureau of cannabis to drive
so many other questions but so the
Bureau of cannabis control establishes
Bureau of marijuana control under Prop
64 is an agency of the state of
California within the Department of
Consumer Affairs charged with regulating
medical cannabis in accordance with
state law pursuant to medical cannabis
regulation Safety Act and then the
agency was charged with creating rules
for the legal non-medical market to take
effect January 1st 2018 so they don't
they call it non-medical cuz i don't
like the word recreational when they
describe you know non-medical use and
what would you prefer as a word just
cannabis youths in general I mean
technically personally I feel like
almost all use is medicinal even though
people don't really realize that most
people use cannabis for a reason to come
home their back hurts or their head
hurts and they're using it for a result
that makes them feel better so that's
medicinal to me yeah so I would say the
vast majority of people that think
they're recreational cannabis users are
more technically medicinally using it
sure there's people to just like to take
16 bong hits and lie on the couch but
you know that's not your typical
cannabis user and that's why I do what I
do yeah exactly that picture yeah that's
the normalization so Maury
it was actually referred to in multiple
media outlets as the state's cannabis
Sardu you the terms ours a weird one too
especially with all this rush of stuff
going on whatnot it's like I've never
liked that foods are oh it's funny okay
so she was appointed by the governor
interesting so so there who was it was
Stevie Angelo was saying on our show he
said that why isn't there a board of
like medical scientists that are that
work directly with the Bureau of
cannabis control that we there could be
more objective sort of and that's what
slowly starting to happen not at this
level but using an example of where
you're going
with it you know federal research has
always been illegal and there's been so
many barriers to actually study in the
plant so for example UCLA has something
called the CRI it's called the cannabis
Research Institute and so technically at
UCLA they're doing some top-level
research and prior to that it was the
only place that was really done was a
couple places I think it was in
Mississippi and the studies were pretty
subpar because of they didn't have a
good product to be studying because they
couldn't access it so the world is
moving to a point where we've got more
data more research and with that comes
more knowledge to change these laws so
it's slow and it's kind of that cyclical
process but it's starting to happen and
the more data and you know empirical
data that we have we can use that to
kind of change these laws slowly yeah I
mean on a global scale there's a I mean
the United States unfortunately in
specially California was such a pioneer
in just driving this forward globally
but because the u.s. is lagging behind
in terms of legalization I mean the
United States is losing the big the big
money for and the big money leads to the
big like educational increases and
infrastructure increases and and medical
increases and all the stuff around the
world and so you know other companies
are going public in Canada Canada's kind
of kicking our ass right now they're
they're ahead of us in the way they've
structured things and yeah so that's an
interesting thing a lot of the Canadian
companies are coming down and buying you
know American stuff and investing money
here there's some weirdness legality
with that that I'm not you know I'm not
a big huge investor guy but it's an
interesting time because Canada it's got
a lot of power right now there's a huge
public companies up there that have a
lot of money and and it's interesting
you know those companies are shipping
cannabis internationally I always found
that really interesting like Canada's
shipping marijuana to Germany and wow
there's some really interesting stuff
that I would have always thought was
illegal but
the world's changing well it's changing
just like that shipping legally across
the world whoa yeah yeah South Korea
just legalized medical cannabis Wow oh
that's a good I think I believe but
South Korea is like the 11th or 12th
largest economy in the world so that's a
huge one yeah most people don't think
about what I don't understand is why
can't this just crumble the the the
walls completely not just of cannabis
but you know all drug use is because
they're doing it maps is it Rick Doblin
you know and the research he's done and
the benefits there as psychedelics as a
medicine cannabis as a medicine no I
don't want to go too deep because we
have an awful crisis right here in our
back in regards to opiates however you
know the war on drugs has to you know be
something else
and yeah and you know granted cannabis
is harmless compared to some other drugs
that are available that are causing
havoc and mayhem for so many Poles right
just be legalized I mean they need to be
heavily regulated of course and you
wouldn't have access to just go buy them
anywhere but technically all drug drugs
should be legalized in my opinion it's
it's stupid not to have that philosophy
so it's just about how you would handle
that philosophy oh wow I mean that's
that's a pretty big asset you got to
speak about it you know and I'm
reluctant to speak about it because what
would that look like you know with the
heavy regulation but still with the leak
completely well I mean like what let's
pick a specific let's use heroin I guess
or something like that you know I mean
yeah well how'd it look like exactly
that's a that's a great question
because I hope it doesn't look like what
it looks like in the back here well I
mean let's think of it like this like
we're we're halfway there with like
we're basically giving safe needle sites
and safe injection sites and allowing on
some level giving people a space to go
do drugs you know you're not legalizing
it but you're making it's safer for
those people that choose to do that so
that's kind of why I say that like you
can create an overall better and by
for the world and again you're not gonna
let people just have access to this like
it's rampant all the sudden like drugs
are for sale everywhere and it's legal
it would be incredibly regulated and and
you know I I don't really think I have I
I'm not I'm gonna be straightforward I'm
not eloquent and educated enough on the
subject to lay out for you exactly how
to implement that but in in the 30,000
foot view I just see and understand why
that would make sense and and mmm-hmm
you know I'd be very interested to see
if someone could summarize it in a
pretty Richard Branson does a great job
doesn't the job he spoke at new us to
two different years and he is he's
really where I kind of picked up that
whole philosophy and listen to him speak
about it and it he speaks about it
better than I yeah yeah interesting is a
complete legalization and regulation of
all drugs very very interesting so I
would I would love to see what that yeah
well how that plan looks completely laid
out now I just want to want to actually
you know get to what it's like can of
dads and also your you know your
speaking around the United States on on
on opioids as well so yeah so teach us
about this so that's been amazing for me
because well I'll give a quick
background like it's gonna be relative
but I'll start off with I I have had 13
people I know commit suicide and suicide
happens because of depression that's
really what leads people to that place
and honestly the opiate addiction in
America is leading people into
depression and then therefore into
suicide suicide rates are off the charts
and I'm not blaming it completely on
opiates but to me personally I've had
not only 13 people I know died of
suicide I know many many people who've
had their lives ruined by opiate
addictions and so to me what I've
learned because I work with a lot of
professional athletes especially
football players and they would sit with
me and be like you know dude we had no
other option we had to take these pills
because we're in so [ __ ] much pain
if we use cannabis we're gonna lose our
jobs or be fined and it's a nightmare so
they are literally forced into this you
know career of having to eat pills like
mms just to be able to wake up and
function and it's it's a very very
unfair thing and that's at the highest
level and then as you trickle down
through America there's a place for
opiates it's probably ninety five ninety
percent over prescribed if you're an
extreme excruciating pain in the
hospital and you've broken all your leg
I mean there's a place for it but so
many people and and the doctor and the
pharmacy doctors and pharmaceutical
industry are really the ones that are
complicit and the ones that have made
this happen and its profit over anything
so yeah we educate through a very
specific manner I bring all these
athletes they tell their stories it's
kind of me as the average Joe and
they're the top pros because I've had my
experience as then and then it's
correlated by a doctor we've got two or
three different doctors that travel with
us and the the one that pops out most to
me is we had four hundred physicians at
Harvard Medical School
sitting enthralled listening to us and
what some of the doctors came and said
to me after was like you know can I get
your card and they told me basically
like we learn nothing about any of these
other alternatives in medical school
like it is absolutely not there for ya
and yeah so it's just it's a it's a
great way using pro athletes to kind of
exemplify the overarching problem of
opiates with that kind of NFL example
but at the end of the day if I went to
my doctor and said oh I hurt my finger
he'd be like here's some vicodin or
here's some percocet you know what any
think twice about it and it just it
disgusts me to be honest with ya and so
I want the world to understand cannabis
is a very very safe alternative to
opiates and if it's done right it really
does help you manage pain do that one
more time in that camera
ready go actually say that one more time
again that was a good sound bite right
there in that yeah exactly what you said
say it again look into the camera and
I'm ready so cannabis is a very very
viable alternative to opiates and well
no okay sorry yeah that's all right I
understand yeah
it's gone well I know my dad sorry but
it was good it was it was good you were
speaking how you were eloquent and I was
I disagree I think you're doing a great
job very very good and it's still is
ringing in my head so profoundly I'm
just like so I just just going right now
it's just like oh my goodness having
medical doctors just be like we were
never told about these things and that
that to me is like uh oh well I mean at
delineating two things Western medical
culture in my mind is awful it's
horrible it's a pharmaceutical culture
and it's about money and medical the the
Western medical philosophy is I'm gonna
be a fat ass I'm gonna eat the wrong
food and not exercise and then give me a
pill to fix myself and the eastern
philosophy is food as medicine what you
put in your body is medicine herbs or
medicine what you eat is gonna make a
difference in how you live and so I love
the eastern philosophy of holistic
health and medicine versus taking a
white pill because you've made bad
decisions for 15 years you know or 20 or
however me that's great China is just
about ready to take control of
everything perfect no I don't know do
baby that just came out that crisper
baby and I you know just the political
culture you know when you when you bring
up this sort of when you when you bring
up what the East has been embodying for
so long in its thousands of years of
history and the way that a child is then
educated by these principles will then
guide that child in a more fruitful
future for society
thank you Ron and so I'm really happy
that that you're bringing it forth as
this like holy [ __ ] look at this main
difference between taking the white pill
to solve the
issues that we just don't do [ __ ] about
versus digging into the thousands of
years of history and love and you know
science and spirituality to really dig
us into oh my god I can let the medicine
be the food left food be thy medicine
and let that process become you and our
medicine you could integrate the two
because at the end of the day not to
completely disparage Western medicine
because there's some amazing things with
surgery and aspects that can save many
many lives that's right but that should
be used as a last resort or as a
complement to the Eastern philosophy not
is the first line of defense yeah not
profiteering cuz time knots have you
heard so that one of the companies that
you know is really more or less
responsible for much of the opiate
addiction I don't know if it's it's
Pfizer or Plex so it's a family actually
that's underneath that but they actually
have an opiate if you overdose it brings
you back and they just raised the price
of this opiate overdose pill eight
hundred percent oh yeah that's right the
pill that when you go to high it brings
you it saves your life if you're an
opiate yeah they raised it eight hundred
percent the price of it yeah just
because they could and I think there's
some federal stuff going on in terms of
an inquiry about that but you know these
companies basically addicted tire
country to opiates and then now they're
gonna start selling you know pills to
fix that addiction and it's I just the
pharmaceutical industry to me are the
true [ __ ] drug czars and drug dealers
and the pharmaceutical to me industry to
me is pure evil question no one's gonna
shut me up on that and I'll say it like
this if the pharmaceutical industry if I
came and said look this pill and we'll
give you the formula will make everyone
healthy and they'll never get sick again
they will lock it in a [ __ ] safe and
never let us find it because they want
to sell us all their [ __ ] other
pills you know and they don't care about
us and it's a very evil industry the
Christ are they they don't care about us
that's the point we gotta get to Jim
that's the bottom line you know all the
obstacles it's something out there and
it's real
lives inside each and every one of us
and it's never gonna reveal itself and
we have to how do you change the minds
you know when they know we're very well
what they're doing everything that we
you know say is not logical there oh
there they are aware of that and they
don't want you to figure it out
yeah and that's where it gets tricky and
we talk about they who are they what the
[ __ ] are you are you that is putting it
in the cage the miracle solution to some
of these problems in the case so that
they can feed us crap along the way
honey they keep us ignorant who is that
day what is channeling through them
what is that negative energy that is
channeling through them and sadly
there's people in this world that don't
give a [ __ ] about other people is what
it comes down to really right I mean
you're either gonna care about the world
in others or you're gonna look out for
yourself and no one else and that's that
crowd I don't think any of us are that
crowd and if I disappear then you know I
guess I disappear but [ __ ] the [ __ ]
pharmaceutical industry it's the good
guys and the Meany pants yeah there's
like there's it's so interesting because
you'll find a our show so based on on
nuance and so when when we when we talk
about this I think to myself like this
is one of those conversations that has
nuance but it's so heavily skewed in the
direction of people that just are trying
to force-feed us crap rather than the
actual solution of food and herbs and
and care and exercise and all this other
kind of stuff so so it's so far skewed
in that in that in that direction so
okay so now what about like what about
candid ads so candid ads is just a
passion project of mine my part one of
my partners in Kenneth litas named Sabo
Shen he and I started it we kind of
became quick friends because we both
have two daughters and I guess
ultimately you know dad's kind of I
don't want to say get the short end of
the stick but you don't really think
about a dad
and being really engaging with your kids
it's usually like you think of the mom
and and I believe as a dad like we need
to spend more time with our kids you
know totally it's really important to
have that male role model so what what I
believe personally is cannabis makes me
a better father and I use a little bit
of cannabis well I'll say it like this
when I used to come home from work
before I would kind of use cannabis at
the level I do now I pour some bourbon
or whatever and I'd be like you know hey
leave me alone or you know I want to
just kind of tune out and if I smoke a
little cannabis I tune in and I'm on the
ground playing with my kids and I'm
building a castle and I'm having a lot
of fun doing it so it really does it
makes me a better father and it makes my
time with my children it makes me enjoy
it and be really more engaged with them
so we have a page on Facebook it's
called canna dads it's got over 2,000
members and basically we just put up
inspirational posts about what we do
with our kids pictures of us out with
our kids and there's usually some
pictures of cannabis and you know
marijuana grows on there as well but
it's mostly about how to be a better dad
and we just kind of support each other
candid dads and see is this one no kin
of dads United and got some info here
it's this one yeah yeah yeah yeah the
one we're here okay awesome I'm making a
join group request alright good pending
nice so let's see yeah here's the page
that's my house in Tahoe
we just went skiing with the daughter
ski with the daughters nice nice the
Mickey look at that door though my god
so dope
SoDo it's little hobbit hut yeah there
was a group I was inspired by a group
called can of moms and and there's a lot
of support out there in the community
for moms around cannabis and just there
wasn't much dialogue a lot about dads
that's my daughter right there too but
I'm actually pleased to see there's
other candidates groups I don't take
that offensively like I think there
should be as many as that's awesome yeah
I actually you bring up this really
really good
point and I want to actually amplify the
amplify the point even further so so the
point the point the point to me is that
there's some good pics to look at from
now that there's this sort of ability to
to take some cannabis and tune into the
present moment with your kids and also
have this sense of awe that comes again
from being a kid and playing with things
that they're playing with and let
they're like learning and experiencing
so when you're there with them you know
that's the real dad you know being there
in those moments I love that that's like
that that's you know that's an
inspirational and with or without
cannabis you just touched on something
like I intrinsically the most important
thing in the world to me is being a
father when I'm put in the ground I want
nothing more than let's say he was an
amazing dad and husband but yeah just
just being engaged with your kids with
or without cannabis makes you makes you
young again it brings you back in your
mindset to see through that lens that
your kids see things and it's it's an
incredible feeling to kind of watch them
and then you know relive that as you as
you see them grow up because you know
when you see this you think about when
you played soccer right because I see it
I think about when I played ya know and
then there you go you're there you're
you know I'm that dad on the sidelines -
I'm the guy that just scream and my
daughter looks at me she's like shut up
so fun yeah so so then let's talk a bit
about Laura where ventures okay so now
where is Aurra going because this is
since July for you yeah as the president
and they acquired new s summit uh-huh so
yeah where are you going with this
consultancy and
full-service firm so what are you
thinking yeah so I have a really really
intelligent partner her name's Jennifer
Sanders shout out Jennifer Sanders shout
out Jennifer and she founded an amazing
lying and I guess franchise for lack of
a better term it's not technically a
franchise called green heart so there's
a product line and there's actually some
brick and mortars in Oregon and just
opening in Las Vegas and so she's
created this amazing and what I love
about this line is it's not just
cannabis like she has an ashwagandha
line and with a green heart inside there
it's it's another set of herbs that you
can use in a tincture form and there's
there's other herbs outside of cannabis
that can be compliment it's kind of on
that Eastern philosophy like you know I
mean tumeric is good for inflammation
and there's so many things that she's
kind of added in where cannabis is one
component of the line but it's not just
the line and I think holistic wellness
is really the word for like where that
is going it's not just about cannabis it
kind of places cannabis alongside all
these other wellness tools so that's
that's a business that she started that
Falls and so underneath Ora and we're
bringing on top-tier clients in the
industry to really help from an outside
professional facet like we've brought in
someone from William Morris
entertainment that's working with us and
we're using data from big data companies
so we're coming into some of the bigger
companies and that don't have the staff
to do this and helping them kind of
reiterate who and what their companies
are we're helping produce events we have
we're actually a rebranding an entire
town up in Canada it's a sovereign
nation I can't say the name of it right
now
but we were hired to help it's like an
Indian nation in Canada and its
sovereign to help them rebrand their
town and there's some benefits because
you can actually produce cannabis you
know in a sovereign nation without some
taxes that you'd have to pay otherwise
so yeah and we're so we're really
looking just for those top-tier clients
and focusing on how to help them scale
and grow their businesses and and hedge
are shipped really to the you know the
a-list players oh that's a great idea
yeah you're you're at they're at the top
of the fitness landscape right now just
working with all the different orgs
aiming to do that as a
keeps growing and blowing up so that's
very smart very smart
I want a powwow on a couple thoughts
that we you know you were you know
you're at towards the end of the show
you were like you know I'm known as an
amazing father and husband that that's
that's what you can't hope I am yeah
yeah if you yeah that's what I'm saying
this like this this intention to just be
you know that for a mom or a dad for
their kids but the kids to grew up and
have that intention to be good stewards
of earth and each other we talk about
that so much so I'm just I'm really
happy that that's something that's so
Kourt to you and makes me feel really
good well that's why I was driven to you
and I enjoy your company so much I think
that you are turning over so many stones
and enlightening so many people by
having amazing guests on your show so I
love I'm one of your what do you call it
a patron saint transporters and I watch
your show all the time and I just think
you you ask great questions and you
really talk about things that matter so
I appreciate your showing you a lot
thank you thank you so much and holy cow
we wouldn't be anything without the
brilliant people I get to sit there and
you know the diverse minds yeah thank
you Mike harden introduced us so I want
to give Mike harden a shout out huge
shout out to Mike harden our leading
some patron and also shout out to big
rocks and almost farms like shout out to
all of his of their orgs that are just
fruit blossoming up you know we've
artist is right across the street so I
told him he was like just like come by
like we'd love to mike is a great mind
for the show I'm really excited to make
that happen at some point so so on that
on that note of like you know having
this care for each other this care for
earth we like to ask a couple questions
towards the end of the show right okay
first question is do you think we're
alone in the cosmos no I don't tell us
why
I think it's just from a desperate
desire to not want to be alone in the
cosmos to be completely honest I don't
have any you know strong spiritual
reasoning why I think there's something
else out there I just in my mind the
universe is so vast and expansive that
to think that were the only things or
intelligent beings out there is just you
know I can't get my head around that so
and like I said at the start I just it's
I think out of a desire to not want to
be the the only ones out there well what
do you think exists past the third
dimension Wow hmm
I don't know what what why don't I turn
this around on you and wait on me what
you think we ask the questions on the
show past a third dimension how about
the fourth and the fifth question I
wanna hear what you think on that one I
gotta hear something if we know the
extent of our own ignorance at least
that's a good thing to do you know so
far you can at least say I don't know
that's a good thing to be able to say
you know do you think we're in a
simulation no this is base reality well
when you say simulation kind of like
what Elon Musk brought up in terms of
like this is we're living in a true
virtual reality or something along those
lines no I don't I don't I can't get my
head around that philosophy you know I
think he owns an intelligent man and I
would listen to that philosophy to learn
more so I wouldn't like to dig my heels
in on it but you know right now if you
ask me that it's pretty firm no I don't
believe that do you
I mean the show's called simulation my
friend you like how I turn these around
Boston yeah every one of our last
question seems like no you answer it's a
lot of nuances it's a good questions you
get questions like asking it what do you
thinks the most beautiful thing in the
world love it's just an undeniable force
and you know I feel sad because I think
some people don't have love in their
lives and they don't feel it and I feel
really lucky to have so much love in my
life and it's love is truthfully to me
what will continue to make the world go
round and it's why humanity is here you
know
humanity's two things Humanity is
beautiful it's awesome like it's why
we're here and it's this crazy
simulation maybe maybe not but
humanity's very very violent and sad and
stark as well you know there's such a
vast definition of what humanity
there's good and bad to it so I I think
love is the basic grounding force and
everything in human life and so if you
don't have love I don't think you really
have anything so to me that's the most
important thing you know force in my
life and I think that's what I get and
why I love my family so much but yeah
without love you know I don't think I'd
want to be around in the world yeah it
is there a different classification of
love for your family than there is for
humanity how do you do that well there's
unconditional love for my family and my
kids you know there's nothing they can
do to change that and I think humanity
you're you can question your faith at
many times I I doubt I will ever have to
question my love for my family it's just
so innate and so in me that there's just
it's it's pretty powerful yeah the human
experiment like you are saying is kind
of nuts with me like darkness is at the
same time that's the lights well it's
you know there's there's two things I
love right now the the feminist movement
and see the empowerment of women and
also men like I mean I'd been
embarrassed my whole life to admit a lot
of things like I cry a lot you know like
I will start crying at movies the
weirdest things I have to hide it you
know I now I don't really care and I
just let it like yeah I'm a crier you
know and I never would have wanted to
say that on film but I feel totally yeah
interval about that and emotions like
being a man you're told like hide your
emotions like I think the opposite
you're a true man if you show your most
you know that's right just when I when I
I weep as well and when I do it just
reminds me that my heart is still alive
and there are things I still care about
and and and I didn't I do I weep at the
the most peculiar instances so feel good
yeah third act thing at times yeah you
know there's a lot of sadness among
there and I'm glad I'm attuned to that
and want to do something about it but
it's just sort of difficult because you
know the dark villain is just so strong
so smart and it doesn't as not
appreciating this conversation at all
and they're gonna shut our [ __ ] down
you know we think we have trouble with
this machine that you know since we
bought it it's not the machine
it's the goddamn gremlins day it's that
but this is a fun show this was really
powerful I liked it a lot
we're normalizing cannabis let's do it
together everyone let's do it yeah we
got a we're gonna joints being lit right
now getting getting the ball rolling
Ronnie's gonna join boom yeah this has
been such a freaking pleasure you are
amazing
we're very grateful to have had yeah
Ronnie's coming on over
it's a blend getting into getting the
shower on getting the shot there it is
boom and I'm actually feeling pretty
good from yeah um but it's like just at
2 3 milligram you're activated activated
that's a good way to put it yeah exactly
feeling good feeling great and also
feeling like we need to spread the
normalization of cannabis message around
the world as you've seen here with the
gym mcalpine you got everything from
Canada to getting away from the opioid
crisis that's going on to getting the
popularization of of Technology with
cannabis at new West summit at the 4:20
games go and hit it up in your city go
and travel to the cities over for 20
games that's happening that hit it up
you said hit it up is that hitting
outside of a hotel is not watch and good
stuff yeah and let's get to the
normalization across the world everyone
let's get there as soon as possible
think about the economics in terms of
the US should be at the forefront of
doing the research on the medical side
we have so much to still do let's get
there together everyone thanks for
tuning in
give us your comments below we'd love to
hear from you about the episode also
going create go and build go and make
cool
things manifest your destiny into the
world everyone thank you Ron for
producing and directing much love
everyone and we'll see you soon
peace
[Music]
you